our next guest began his career as a
sportscaster in Oklahoma City and he is
considered to be one of the reasons why
Kevin Durant decided to leave the
Thunder from there he went on an epic
search for love that lasted nearly two
decades part therapist part referee
parts shoulder to cry upon he's
perfected the art of pretending everyone
has a chance for romance even that
dental hygienist from Denver who started
crying 15 minutes into the first night
but it's great a skill being able to
figure out who's Lauren and who's Ashley
please welcome the host to the bachelor
and bachelorette Chris Harrison yeah
that might be the greatest thing because
that is the hardest part of my job okay
who's Lauren who's Ashley it feels like
every other girl is named Lauren er
Ashley now is that by design this season
with Colton you guys realize I might be
the first in the history of the show
no Lauren's oh not one Lauren it really
upset everybody did you bar Lauren
somebody named Lauren their actual name
might be Lauren but you changed I'm
sorry your name is Sarah usually yeah
you know it's Lauren B Lauren I Lauren Z
we had a lot of Lourdes and and and
typically it takes me weeks to figure
out which Lauren is which and it's but
no Lauren's this season do you study
before the season starts I used to I
think back when I cared now I used to
honest to god you know just because
coming from my sportscasting days and
all that I would pregame and I used to
know everybody's name their hometown
every their little BIOS night one they
would walk out a limo and I'm like okay
that's Kelly she's from st. Louis she
just I used to know all that now not so
much
how tough is it when somebody wants to
leave they're not ready to leave and you
have to kind of tell them you got to
stay like do you have to you know
part-time therapists I'm guessing but
you have to talk how often you talk
contestants off the edge contestants
wise less it's more about The Bachelor
the Bachelorette for me they're they're
the ones I'm really guiding the rest
kind of happens around them I mean
whatever happens around them is the
reality of it and that's fine I'm really
concerned with what is Colton doing
well you know what is our Bachelorette
doing how do I help them as much as
possible or go in and you know and stir
things up and and roll the proverbial
grenade in the room to kind of create
some drama create a circumstance that
will lead to some drama that's that's
more of what I'm concerned with okay you
you have these moments where is your job
like do you try to sex things up a
little bit here or does somebody else do
that honestly do I sex things well no do
you go in and go call me I've heard
Colton take off your shirt like days
some Adele do instructs the fluffer
never have to take I never him up I'd
have to do any of that okay I took that
out of my contract season two but he's
in the shower every scene well I think
the deal was Ari who was our last
bachelor was like the most sure did
bachelor layers upon layers on Ari
so I think we just we the other pendulum
swings in life and I think we went from
Ari to this guy will never have a shirt
on ever how often do you meet is it more
men or women who want to be on the show
I think it's equal that's a good
question I think it's actually equal you
know when we're out here it at Pebble
and you're at the 18 t there's a lot of
guys like hey can you get me on the show
and their wives are standing and usually
the wife's like please take him yeah
he's a real gem but it's really equal
like there I will say what's grown over
the years honestly thanks in large part
to you guys
the Howard Stern's the Jimmy Kimmel's of
the world that have kind of made it just
cool for guys to talk about and okay
that there are a lot of athletes and a
lot of guys that are into the show what
McLovin
okay just ask a couple questions okay
I'm really into this season now Colton
Underwood is famously a virgin he's
about 27 right for someone who might
have gone into his twenties choice
stories are like my situation where just
happened that way you know like you were
swinging for the fences you just found
out you had warning track power yeah I
would have taken a few doubles at night
since you were mostly single so no I
think with colton it was a mixture of
things i think it was religion for a
while very conservative and then i think
when he got to the point where okay i'm
not just saving myself for marriage i
just like to meet a special woman then
he did and i think he spoke a little bit
about that with Kailen there was a
circumstance where he was in a
relationship where somebody was had been
abused and they were dealing with some
issues and then for the next few years
it just it just never happened and then
as he told me you know maybe it would
have happened with becca but she dumped
me before we got the fantasy suite so it
was started with religion he is a
conservative guy but then circumstances
kind of led him to where he is yes okay
so this season
I saw a tease that a woman said she was
really uncomfortable the fact that
Colton is courting all these other women
too and I've heard that before
how could he contest and say I'm
uncomfortable you know what they're
getting into but what are they're
they're like I'm uncomfortable with this
format well and there's there's all
that's happened many times where they'll
say you know anything along those lines
and early on I get it there was some
naivete and there were some innocence
we've been on for 17 years you know it's
you can do a little homework and watch
the show before you come on and it
always cracks me up if someone says I
I've never seen the show before I'm like
yeah yeah you're on the show you've seen
the show he's Chris Harrison hosted The
Bachelor The Bachelor this season Colton
Underwood and a terra's Monday at 8 p.m.
on ABC accidental nudity like how much
nudity do you are you exposed to on the
show too much too much really yeah
there's a lot you know a lot of times
unfortunately with the band it never
happens with the person you would like
it's with Colton or re you know my go
boy yeah cuz often times we are
somewhere around the world and getting
changed in the back of vans and I mean
it's not as glamorous as it seems
sometimes you know with these crazy
locations if we're on a glacier or
whatever and you're just huddled for
warmth and you got to change real quick
and so unfortunately it's kind of like a
nude beach it's never who you want to be
in the nude beach did you almost retire
as the host no no I love what I still
love what I do and I still have that
passion
I almost said my my my passion buckle
but and by the way you did give each
other I shouldn't I didn't almost retire
why what have you heard well no because
they did sort of a retrospective I know
and then I thought people I got a lot of
calls that it was so we did this big
premiere this this this year mainly it
was to get out of the way the national
championship game ABC's like look just
fill the time but they you know we were
shooting in Dallas they had my mom and
then they I thought they were just gonna
pull up some embarrassing photos and
maybe a video or something and they
showed this amazingly touching
retrospective video of and I thought I'm
either a dying or be I'm fired or
retiring so I I haven't heard the latest
okay I think I'm still around all right
my mom won't tell me if you lose that
job what's the ideal sports job you'd
like I think it would be golf it would
be the 18th tower I'll knock Jim Nantz
off take his job do you think you could
take Nance I can say hello friends no
it's I would think I would love going
back to sports casting would be doing
play-by-play somewhere football my goal
in life was to be the voice of the
Dallas Cowboys that's all I ever wanted
to do was move back home to Dallas be a
sportscaster be the voice of the Cowboys
but I think now golf didn't you sneak
into a Cowboys Super Bowl Super Bowl 30
how'd you do it my my late boss mentor
Bill teegan's and I we had press passes
but back then you know the main guy
would get an actual ticket to go and
watch the game and I was gonna go to an
auxilary tent and we're in in Tempe at
Arizona and cowboy Steelers and I just
started walking with him he said well
walk with me as far as you can then
you'll have to go to the tent and I'll
go in and back then pre 9/11 all that
stuff lot less security I realized I was
pretty much in the arena - this one
little guardrail and there was a space
in it and so I just looked around and
they really hadn't setup security yet
and I just he was walking he was talking
and I just took a beeline and I I walked
into the stadium I was kind of already
in there just act like you know where
you're going exactly I walked into the I
walked into a bathroom and they were
already letting people into the stadium
smoke off my press pass took up
everything else and I just walked out
like I was
and I found a seat and I got really
lucky cuz I thought I was sitting in his
seat and I was sitting in it was like
pee our wives so you know all the PR
directors for all the teams it was their
wives section and they kind of adopted
me and took me in I was younger and
better-looking at the time and and they
kind of adopted me and I fit into this
section and I watched the Cowboys beat
the Steelers has being on the
bachelor/bachelorette helped you with
lines like in your love life like does
it help you know what to say and not to
say I think it honestly tell it if I'm
being truthful I've become a much better
listener shut up and listen yeah yeah
and actually and ask questions and and
pay attention it's helped me you know of
all the things that you know hosts do
and in this game there's very few really
good talented talk show hosts it because
they just go off this script and they
don't listen and I think it's actually
taught me to listen and in my work life
but also in my love life got a little
serious there I'm in Amazon it to be
light-hearted know I know good lines I
know cuz there's some cheesy stuff it
said on another horribly cheesy yes it's
where cliches go to die but some do
somebody help write the cheese no it's
it's nuts
oh god yeah yes sadly it's natural
that's what that's what that's why
people come on the show that's what it's
like out there that's how bad it is but
how do you know somebody's crazy at what
point do you know they're crazy you know
at first of all I will say this we don't
cast the crazy you don't have to people
think oh come on you don't have to close
this set off right now for the six of us
are crazy eventually yeah four of these
guys are in tears in an hour but you
know you really did that you can't fake
that I mean it's not like we have Meryl
Streep on the show these are just people
from all walks of life it's just what
you do is you take away their defense
mechanisms and all the things that they
kind of rely on in life and they're left
to their own devices and left our own
devices we're usually not good it's
great to see you good to see you and uh
Congrats on your success but you're not
retiring now retiring that I know of
okay and you usually give us a little
bit of something to look forward to just
a more so here and it's a parting gift a
parting gift B let's talk about the jump
heard around the world
a lot of rumors heard you know the
Dajjal
this is Colton's famous Johnny went over
the fence over the fence okay first of
all as far as athleticism goes
phenomenal and I hope they will show
this in the credit bed I went back and
nobody knows this I went back along with
a lot of producers about seven of us the
next day to try and recreate what he did
because all night we were having a few
cocktails thinking could you do that
because it's about a seven and a half
foot fence and we went over it you know
like like there's a pruder film like
okay he went up he didn't touch his foot
never touched going up or over the top
he won hopped it and he is taller so he
had leverage but I'm like I think I can
do it it took me three or four tries I
did it and then some producers tried not
easy but that is coming up in a few
weeks
there's Colton find love that's all I
care about Chris I don't know if we've
revealed that yet really be a virgin at
the end of this that's a question Willy
does he have warning track power can you
put it over the fence that's the big
question will he be a virgin at the end
of the band can't reveal that but give
me a shot here I'll say this I'll say
he's happy he's really happy how many
times
let's let's be honest okay he is a
virgin so if he's happy he's like I'm
happy
Colton Underwood the star Bachelor airs
Monday at 8:00 Eastern East Chris
Harrison Chris thanks for joining us
thanks guys for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]